[Music]
10:44 Eastern Time Friday September
tonight what day is it Mike Henry
guys on board call at 9:44 it was Malibu
calendar the press came in got a move a
couple things
I want to make sure I'm understanding
what you're saying here you're super
pumped about the thought process and
strategies behind post-production of the
daily be vlog on YouTube because you
love the YouTube ecosystem yeah I'm
feeling great but I'm also a little bit
more patient than everybody right like
if today's is not good I'm feeling great
about that too right it'll also give us
context will read the qualitative
feedback from the audience a lot of them
are still gonna say it's great because
they just like me I'm filming daily be
today we are changing our style so
usually we just document garius whole
life we make a narrative out of that
we're trying to go to more of the
creative route we're so used to
recording everything and we're really
trying to push against that kind of
balance when to film why not
[Music]
[Music]
this is the askgaryvee show
little layover
boss thank you so much for coming
tonight lovely name I love your [ __ ]
12:04 we managed to set it up to squad
we roll deep yeah yeah yeah you know the
word we get a roof drop in here okay I
got there you got fired
done okay everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk so to 64 of the ask gary
vee show i developed a product it's
coming up on a year now that transforms
cremated remains into a glaze for
ceramic design object Tony admit right
now this is a three this show that
you've ever been on this guy is dead
people turning into glaze this is this
is kind of a new informant she's a big
idea
I'm always okay
nobody's so well I was really gonna try
how's it going are you doing some of the
new stuff or it's like it's tough
finding that cancer takes time I didn't
realize we weren't that we weren't
editing dailyvee yesterday I'm in charge
of everybody though I could have made
somebody not busy I could have decided I
just need to know and I know you were
sick so it was a perfect storm the fact
that we were we're back in episode 2 is
not do you two different colored eyes
yeah
how the [ __ ] that before yeah thank you
he just rolled up on you everybody this
is gary vay-ner-chuk i'm so - six five
of the askgaryvee show
and the amount of music i consumed from
the man that is sitting across from me
right now
should be illegal when I was 18 John
this is what I would play I'm like okay
I'm 18 and in 18 years I'm gonna be 36
that's young as [ __ ] I have my whole
life in forget everything I just lived I
have all that time in front of me and
I'm still gonna be 36 now I'm 41 and I'm
like okay I flew this whole life okay
41 I'm gonna be 82 hey Susan I like even
with the game that I've played my whole
life about doubling up my number to make
me realize how much time I still had so
[ __ ] be patient do the right thing
shortcuts kill you like do it right I I
still do it I'm really yeah
there's a lot of fun good episode give
to me culture attention there's so many
things going on in the world that are
winning but when you can combine your
interest with what's winning you attack
it and for me hip-hop is an interest of
and then I attacked the people that I
know I know Russ is gonna be one of the
biggest artists in Warren in three or
four years and we started establishing
relationship paying forward I'm putting
him on trying to get as much for him as
possible you build a real relationship
you're not doing it
he expects something in return you do
the right things the right things happen
what up my man
I get it
how's it going I love it
it's going well I'm just consuming
consuming all the content the feedback
on social listen I really enjoyed our
time together the other day makes me
happy ed of course take care
heading home going into weekend going
garage saling tomorrow which is my
favorite pastime Sunday New York Jets
Buffalo Bills my official daily be Jets
prediction Buffalo Bills 16 New York
Jets 9 and that is my hope I mean I love
my Jets I know people say real fans
don't cheer for losses that is just not
practical or strategically correct
I am hoping for in a world where there's
big-time quarterbacks coming into the
draft I'm hoping for a top pick the
number one pick a lot of music in the
air right just Dustin Russ stop by the
conversation I just had with Dustin was
an entrepreneurial conversation the
conversation you know we have a thrust
it's an entrepreneurial conversation
entrepreneurship is oxygen across
everything regardless of what you do you
need to figure out how to get people to
give a [ __ ] about it and then act on it
and no matter what you're trying to
achieve which is bring awareness to
hurricane relief or trying to sell your
t-shirt brand respecting your audience
bringing them value and the
delivering on that product that's the
part that people forget delete that
shirt can't be shitty vaynermedia
services can't be shitty that song songs
can't be shitty and do everything right
but if the product is [ __ ] you're dead
and so that is the focus going in to
this weekend for me you're consuming
this early in the week so let that be
the rest of your week
and let's [ __ ] get it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]